I hate RomComs.
They're full of the same tired tropes.
For example, when sperm and egg meet, there's
a LITERAL SPARK.
Ugh.
So, over it.
Hello everyone!
I'm Crystal here for DNews.
Recently, researchers from Northwestern University
reported the discovery a “zinc spark”
in human oocytes.
This phenomena, known to occur in other mammalian
species, is the result of sudden releases
of zinc after egg fertilization.
Before mammalian eggs or oocytes are either
released by the ovaries or harvested by a
doctor,
they absorb billions of zinc atoms that act
as a signal for them to halt meiosis cell
division and wait to be fertilized.
They're in a holding pattern until they meet
a sperm.
If they DO meet one… at that moment of fertilization
several things have to happen all at once.
First, the egg has to protect itself from
the insertion of DNA from multiple sperm,
which it does by using sodium ions to set
up an electric fence around the cell.
Then, it releases calcium to, among other
things, harden the outer vitelline membrane
surrounding the egg and make it impenetrable
to other sperm.
Once it's protected itself it needs to rev
up its metabolism and start dividing.
But it can only do that by releasing all its
zinc ions in a series of strong bursts.
Scientists call these “sparks”!
Zinc sparks have been observed in a bunch
of other mammals, but until this study we
weren't sure whether they occurred in humans.
To determine whether we do it too, scientists
bathed human oocytes in a petri dish of fluorescent
dye that can only emit light when zinc is
present.
At the beginning of the experiment all the
zinc was inside the cells so they saw no signal,
but then they injected an RNA construct into
the oocytes to emulate fertilization, and
it worked!
They observed a burst of light from around
some eggs indicating their zinc had been released.
To be clear, scientists didn't want to make
actual humans in the lab, so they didn't ACTUALLY
fertilize the eggs with human sperm.
Instead, scientists used a synthetic blank
RNA construct common in this type of experiment.
From the study results, the scientists were
able to conclude that human eggs, like those
of mice and non-human primates do exhibit
the “zinc spark” (which is cool), *and*
that the zinc signal can be used as an indication
of health and embryonic progression after
fertilization!
This is even cooler!
If this technique were to migrate from the
lab to the doctor's office, it could have
a significant impact on In-Vitro Fertilization
(IVF) because that spark is proof that progression
into an embryo has begun.
While you will probably never see these zinc
sparks, they're happening every time a sperm
successfully fertilizes an egg -- this "spark
of life" can tell researchers and IVF doctors
which eggs are good.
This is helpful, because IVF normally involves
artificially bringing together harvested eggs
and sperm from potential parents.
After they meet, the zygotes are implanted
into the woman's womb, then… everyone crosses
their fingers, and they often implant more
than one, to increase the odds of success.
Even still, the CDC reports women under 35
have the best chance for IVF success, but
that rate is only around 40%.
The ability to visualize these newly discovered
zinc bursts at the time of fertilization could
guide selection of healthy, successfully fertilized
eggs for implantation improving pregnancy
success rates, reducing the need for repeat
procedures, lowering costs and easing the
long, expensive and emotionally draining process
for potential parents.
Go science!
Sponsor?
Embryonic cells can be used for a ton of amazing
things!
Learn more about how we can grab Stem cells
guilt-free in Julian’s video here:
Are there any
other human processes you want to know about?
I'd love to dig more into them for you, so
let me know in the comments and be sure to
subscribe to DNews so you can see the answer!